let's start with the drama Harry has
touched down now in the UK
how is he going to be a part of this or
not a part of this well the fact that
he's coming over means he is going to be
a part of it I'm going to be and we will
all be watching very closely the seating
arrangements now where is he going to be
is he going to be right at this at the
heart of the action is he going to be
close to the Wales is you know he's not
speaking to his brother so whoever's
overseeing that seating plan has a
pretty tricky job because I think it
would look pretty chillish for him to be
seated anywhere towards the back my
understanding is there have been
conversations between Charles and Harry
and but that's really as far as it's got
and I don't think he's going to get a
particularly warm reception from the
family did Megan make the right decision
and not coming I think it probably was a
wise decision by the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex for Harry to come over and Megan
to stay behind of course they've got
Archie's fourth birthday you know a
coronation trumps a fourth birthday well
possibly and you could have celebrated
with your fam you could have come and
celebrated with your family I think it
was probably the right decision because
I think had she come how'd she come with
the children I think there was always
the risk that that sort of the Sussex
show could have overshadowed the
coronation and what is the King's moment
he's waited 64 years for this moment no
one has to overshadow and I think there
is a very real possibility that had they
come here they may have been booed in
the streets and that would have been
terrible wow do you think there is ever
any coming back for Megan and Harry you
think they can fix this they have these
grandchildren that you know those are
Charles's grandkids they're Charles's
grandchildren they are prince and
princess they are you know they they are
part of the royal family I think it's
something of a
positive Omen that Harry's going to be
here I mean of course he didn't have to
come and I think had he not come that
would have been a riff that we would
have said was was that was it you know
there was no coming back from this but I
think every time he comes here every
time there is a family moment that that
forges away for a Reconciliation
certainly with his father but I think in
terms of his relationship with his
brother that's going to be much harder
by the way do your sources have they
told you anything about how Harry's
doing in California does he miss it here
at all you live your entire life
someplace there happened to be little
things you missed like friends and
family yeah I mean I I hear that it's
certainly in the in the early days he
was really missing his friends he was
missing his family and he was missing
England but you only need to leave
through the pages of spare to realize
how unhappy he was within the royal
family I mean he's told me that on
occasions you know that that sense that
he wishes he wasn't born a prince I
think he had been looking for a way out
for a long time this is a new and
exciting life I think the big question
is what's he going to do now
[Music]
thank you